[موسيقى]
مجموعة النمل سميت على اسم حشرة صغيرة
ولكن الشركة ضخمة في الصين.
النمل هو الذراع المالية لشركة علي بابا
للتجارة الإلكترونية التي أسسها
الملياردير جاك
ماو حقًا جوهرة تاج جاك ما
وليس مجرد مزحة جاك ما  إنه
فخور حقًا بالإنترنت في الصين
ويشتهر بـ alipay الذي
يسمح للمستخدمين
بإرسال أموال حوالة مالية للأصدقاء والاستثمار في
أسواق المال
وأكثر من ذلك ، فهو حرفيًا سوبر ماركت مالي
يمكنك استخدامه إلى حد كبير alipay لكل
شيء
بدأه alipay كخدمة ضمان
لـ e  - منصة التجارة في عام
2004 ،
كان التسوق عبر الإنترنت جديدًا في الوقت الذي
لم يكن لدى العديد من الصينيين بطاقات ائتمان
ولم يكن المشترون والبائعون يثقون في بعضهم
البعض
عندما بدأت قبل 80 عامًا ،
يقول الجميع أن جاك هذا هو النموذج الأكثر
غباء الذي رأيناه على الإطلاق
لن
يستخدمه أحد وأقول إنني لا أهتم بما إذا كان هذا
النموذج علميًا سواء كان
مظهرًا رائعًا أم لا طالما أنه يعمل ،
فهو يساعد في بناء الثقة
اليوم ، Alipay هو أداة دفع
رقمية  غير
أن لديها أكثر من 700 مليون مستخدم في
العام الماضي تقريبًا ،
فقد ولدت حوالي 17 تريليون دولار من
المدفوعات
ولكن النملة أكثر بكثير من مجرد مدفوعات رقمية
ومجموعة متنوعة من
الخدمات المالية والمنتجات التي أصبحت
جزءًا من الحياة اليومية للمئات  من
ملايين الأفراد والشركات في
جميع أنحاء
الصين ، من الصعب للغاية
المبالغة في تقدير التأثير الذي أحدثته هذه الشركة
على الأفراد الصينيين ، وكان أحد
أكثر المنتجات التي ابتكرتها النمل شهرة هو أورباو
يويباو ، مما يعني أن الكنز المتبقي
يتيح للمستخدمين أخذ المال من
خلال محافظ أليباي الرقمية
واستثمارها  في أسواق المال ،
يمكن للناس أن يستثمروا ما لا يقل عن 1 يوان أو
15 سنتًا في
غضون أشهر من إطلاق yuebao كان لديه
عشرات الملايين من المستخدمين في الصين
، وقد قامت المجموعة بعمل جيد جدًا
لفهم ما
يجب أن تكون عليه تجربة المستخدم للمستهلكين الصينيين المحليين
، السؤال الحقيقي  هل يمكنهم تكرار
ذلك في الأسواق الخارجية
ولكن قد لا يتمكن النمل وأليباي من
تكرار هذا النجاح  erseas
الآن خاصةً عندما تكون بكين وواشنطن محاصرتين
في ما يبدو وكأنه قتال لا نهاية له
على
التكنولوجيا وشركات التكنولوجيا الصينية عالقة
في مرمى النيران ،
إنه لأمر مؤسف في كثير من الأحيان أن
التكنولوجيا والأسواق المالية
الآن ضيقة للغاية بيئة سياسية
وليست ودية للغاية
ستستمر البيئة تجاه الشركة الصينية لفترة
[موسيقى]